you
hi everyone it's Jerry I am on Leach s
org and I'm gonna play a quick five
minute game no increment on this one so
let's see what we get first time playing
against this opponent Albin JP so let's
see what we get here let's make sure we
get in d4 before it's not possible all
right I want to drop the knight back and
see if they choose to give up the strong
bishop to damage my structure I don't
want to play e3 to support the pawn
because I have this in mind I want to
put my pawn on e4 Souma Roxy bind and
grip over d5 want to control these two
pawn breaks if possible and now that
square let's see if we could maybe
control c6 with a pawn one day and then
have a light square bishop exchange but
a piece here how do we do all this let's
start with Queen d2 so this controlling
c6 I anticipate that when I drop my
knight in to d5 it'll be captured so I
have a pawn around controlling this
square and unprepared to meet that move
with this securing here and also my
Bishop rook c8 and b3 I guess this is
also a possibility b3 is solid where's
this Knight headed I'm not sure
let's start with this last piece in the
ball game you know it's right on this
point the Queen kind of struggles some
oh that's a really big weakness okay
it's aimed at controlling uh it's aimed
at controlling or maintaining the knight
on c5 but it's certainly weakens these
squares these two so I could like to
target them you know I'm just gonna jump
right in
why not and maybe I make another push
now let's do this just getting out of
the line of fire
I had this where under control be a
little bit careful this is where the
black pieces intersect in my position
yeah but I I thought that this would
have been a good idea nice follow up by
missing and now aides dream I think a
three hmm maybe not a three rook c8 and
I have a some concern about this move
and my knight has to go here tell you
what I'm gonna go here it feels a little
bit awkward but I'll I like having my
rook play CC for directly and maybe
maybe he jumps into this square he's not
the greatest piece in fact why not
follow up with this and then I wouldn't
even need a three at that point okay but
I do have to be a little bit careful in
fact I should probably be considering f4
here now f4 there's only Knight here hmm
here's a
and maybe you know I'm just gonna go for
a dark square bishop exchange this is my
better Bishop but there's still a lot of
pieces on board and if I could get rid
of this key defender okay forget about
that huh if only I could get rid of that
guy
he's not going anywhere okay well here's
here's the nice thing it's that without
my bishop here if ever this I could drop
back to a nice square okay so this this
really feels like the right way to do it
stopa nning up the bishop sighs some
Brooke now black avoided the dark square
bishop exchange but has to be on the
lookout for back rank mates at some
stage we still are working with all
major pieces so I wouldn't be surprised
if at some stage black says you know out
okay I'm fearing for my King's life
let's trade bishops and so now I think I
am gonna go in for this this idea that I
had some time ago which is to plant a
piece on that c6 square and I believe I
will be getting a passed pawn now and
it's going to be connected and I'm
threatening mate by the way say with a
poem and then superglue this guy right
in there
there we go Knight is under control with
the bishop this structure basically
kills both major pieces and now I'm
ready to win the Knight f4 game over
this is the game over move yeah nothing
nothing doing here he's out of squares
nearly resign okay Gigi yeah I basically
just wanted to do a quick game for well
a couple reasons one it's been a while
since I uploaded a five minute blitz
game and if you caught my previous video
the pinned comment to my previous video
I'm working on a different audio setup
so it's a mini a mini audio test as well
so let's just dive in here and see if we
can maybe take a thing or two away from
this quick game let me go ahead and hit
the computer analysis see what it has to
say so just going through here let's
give it a second see where we stand with
the inaccuracies mistakes and blunders
shouldn't take more than 30 seconds okay
well while it's thinking let's go
through the opening a little bit what do
we have here what are they calling it
Sicilian in Sicilian invitation whoo I
had no idea okay there's the fancy graph
inaccuracies mistakes and blunders for
each let's see Bishop g7 I'm just gonna
flick on the evaluation straightaway now
top suggestion that's a scary thing to
do though I didn't want to do this
because of Knight f6 and then let's just
say Bishop e2 there's d5 so I wanted to
squeeze a little bit more out of my e
pawn so that's why
just went back to c2 and then got this
formation
it's basically able to express
everything I wanted to in this game it's
difficult for black you know playing
without I have some space black is
playing with all minor pieces still and
at a certain point these you know
developing moves run out and it's kind
of like well how do you improve further
in black finds it more difficult to
improve further than white much easier
for me to maneuver so any I don't know
it just seems like it's a growing
advantage here right I think it's an
evaluation that we could trust
so maybe yeah this is this is really I
don't know it's a very weakening move
eventually both my Knights ended up on
these nice squares in the in Black's
house and black we really wasn't able to
establish any peace in my position so I
mean I I'm thinking the improvement has
to be somewhere right around here so
instead of b6 I think black has to be
prepared to knock out the night once he
arrives on d6 and this really turns out
to be an issue the recapture and to have
a pawn control a hole in your opponent's
position and to be so deep there on the
c6 turns out to be a problem so the
suggestions Bishop e6 and Knight to d7
let's just have a look at 97 see a few
moves how it's playing out the computers
always gonna recommend this scary this
seems more human
this little reposition unmasking the
bishop and putting the knight on c5 and
it's even considering going to e6 next
let's just say I went with f3 oh now f5
okay this just gives at least a little
bit of a different feel for how black
can approach this position and it starts
with unmasking the bishop we'll really
two things unmasking the bishop and
later we're seeing a suggestion of
playing f5 so this would this at least
allows black some type of active plan
whereas you know these moves out over
here once once a5 is in you can forget
about the b5 pawn break and I just have
so many pieces on d5 that the d5 break
is out of you know that's not working
either yeah so this little reposition
combined within f5 is a way to approach
this in a more active way for black but
as this one played out it's just a slow
improving position and I enjoy a space
advantage it's just uh growing from here
doesn't like Knight 283 it likes night
to a3 one of my concerns at this point
was what oh if I played a if I play to
a3 here my concern was rick c8 within a
6 next 94 and e6 not here I'm dropping
c4 chop
chopping okay so I could drop a pawn but
in the end have something good happening
on d6 okay I'm I just didn't even want
to enter a position where I dropped upon
to hold everything together
I could play off four here but went with
this just wanted to play within the
structure many approaches at this stage
in the night arriving on c6 is just a
killer and in the end he ends up getting
trapped at this stage okay well as
mentioned just a quick video it's been a
while for a blitz game as usual feel
free to leave any feedback to this one
in the comment section below hope you're
having a great day and I will catch you
in the next video that's all for now
take care bye
you